hello everyone welcome back to our
podcast we're not gonna say the name
because we don't want to get deep
monetize but this is gonna be a great
let me say our name we came as Aaron II
we're gonna think about what we're gonna
do about that because we don't have to
we don't want that to get in our way for
the rest of our careers rule but we can
say our real names
yeah who's here today well me I'm
Jessica
I'm Bo's I'm Tiffany note if I liked if
I'm the cool so we'll call you in
trouble name but also I kind of liked
the intro I know you girl yeah so today
we have this really exciting topic and
you guys know I love the sexual topics
and we're going to talk about losing our
virginity I remember mine very clearly
but I kind of want to see where you guys
how many times it take you to lose your
virginity whoa more than what yeah three
times three no I tried losing in three
oh so there was not penetrating go how
did that okay explain okay so like the
first time I'm like well the first time
I was like you can't go in my this hole
because then I want to save it for
marriage so let's do the other one that
last I talked about it in a different
episode but it went in and I was like
immediately take it out second time was
Valentine's Day we had been together for
wait how old were you oh sorry I was 16
years of age high school I was in high
school but my boyfriend and I had been
dating for almost a year at Valentine's
Day our anniversary was in March so on
Valentine's Day it was like almost a
year and I was like I'm gonna marry this
guy so it's okay like under the eyes of
God it's okay and I did you're saving
everything less buzzing I got condoms I
got because I was very paranoid about
getting pregnant so I was like I got
condoms I'm on birth control pills I'm
uh
I got nontox all nine like what is that
the [ __ ] spermicide no knocks all
nine is the ingredient in spermicide
that's kind of bad for you
yeah but spermicide yeah that was that
didn't you yeah how does that put it's a
Lube you put it on the condom or
the penis or whatever you already have a
condom it's just and condoms sometimes
have it lubricating the inside yeah but
I was just extra paranoid about getting
pregnant because I was like I can't be
having a teen pregnancy so yeah we try
to lose it in my car because that's
where you try to lose it when you don't
have a home to go to lose it and it
wouldn't go in
it was just like it wouldn't even like
barely yeah like not even the tip could
go in but nothing was going to we're so
scared and it was like and it just hurt
I also tampons are hard we're hard to
put another time
but then the third time it was our
anniversary I got a hotel room because
it was attached to the restaurant I
worked at so we got a discount of one of
the waiters got it for us we did be 18
to rent the hotel room so where the
waiters got yeah we ordered Chinese food
from our favorite Chinese food place got
some orange chicken of course I've got a
bottle champagne from one of the waiters
that like knew that was going on that
night hostess and so it was like they
were all older they were in college and
like I was like the little hostess oh my
god she was virginity tonight so the
immunity of that brought my brother's
PlayStation to say your brother no no no
II
we played eight mile and it didn't feel
like it was gonna go in and like to the
point where I was crying we gave up so I
am yeah how do you keep it hard that all
time I don't know I mean he was
teenagers true but then he started
joking like no it's okay it's okay I was
sad I felt like I disappointed him and
he was like no no it's okay oh this
feels so good
who the kid it's so good like he's just
joking with you but that actually
relaxed me enough that it did start to
go in oh and then it was like oh not
only does it like he's it going in but
it's starting to not hurt ya anymore and
then we did it we lost our virginity to
each other and it burned like [ __ ] after
it's like a road rash for the first
inside your body yeah
damn yeah so that's that was my story
damn three times three times but I'm
glad it happened on the last one and not
like the on the side of the mountain
road one oh right yeah it was a perfect
scenario with champagne and and all the
bed
right and my favorite Chinese food yeah
my favorite Chinese food Ming Dynasty
shoutout Goleta California you ever in
town that out they didn't sponsor this
no if they're still around but we used
to go on every one-month anniversary we
would go to Ming Dynasty and so it was
kind of like tertiary anniversary losing
the virginity plus Ming Dynasty is gonna
help us get the hot popular guy in
school do you want to own yourself is
the first monthly fashion service to
bring a personalized boutique experience
to us after taking a super quick 60
second style quiz you'll receive a
personalized showroom of pieces
specifically catered towards your own
unique style so whether you're the
preppy girl or the punk rock girl you'll
probably find something on ShoeDazzle so
they released brand-new Styles
collections and prints every month and
you can save 30 to 50 percent when you
become a VIP VIPs can get free shipping
on orders over $39 and have access to
member only sales and there is no
commitment to order as a VIP that's
right so you can get your first
ShoeDazzle style for as low as $10
that's 75% off your first item with our
special link which is ShoeDazzle comm
slash b tch and so you can take
advantage of this deal right now that is
ShoeDazzle dot-com slash b tch to get
your first style for as low as $10
that's sh o e da ZZ le comm slash b tch
and please make sure to enter your email
dress once you take your style quiz
because then you'll receive monthly
exclusive discounts and the inside scoop
about new collections that haven't been
released yet again ShoeDazzle dot-com
slash b tch yeah yeah get you some shoes
cover them feet stop walking around
barefoot story I was also 16 and so
apparently I mean this guy was also a
virgin and we were just like man I I had
already reached the point where I mean
I'm Mexican girl and I was going to like
a high school where there was a majority
of us and so a lot of us are very
sexually active at a very young age so
me being 16 it's like girl year-old
what's happening yeah I was kind of I
lost mine wait before you but go ahead
yeah yeah so then this guy - he was he
had also been a virgin so I don't know
like once we got to know each other like
I remember meeting him and I immediately
I was like oh my gosh I have like such a
huge crush on this guy and he was kind
of like he was kind of a jerk to me
where he was just kind of like yeah
whatever
like okay yeah let's hang out and I was
like all right but anyway so then we
were talking for a while and this also
by the way this kid he was like a rich
kid and like I
there was no rich kids at my school but
like he would drive like an m3 and [ __ ]
like a Beemer and he lived like it this
really really nice mansion in North
Downey which is where like the rich
Mexican people live like the white
people I lived like that kind of got
pushed down that's where they used to
live and so yeah so it was just a whole
bunch of pushed down yeah people that
got white people mansions now the
Mexican right in and they're the ready
to go over a neighborhood the white
happens exactly white plate that was the
area anyway so then one night we were
just I was just like listen man it has
to happen and it's it's it's gonna be
you
gonna be gonna be you this is gonna
happen cuz I'm tired of being a virgin
it was really like this disease I want
to get rid of right yeah exactly
she's like once a year it of it exactly
that's exactly I totally related to her
in in that show so then we ended up
planning this thing where and before
that before we actually lost our
virginity to each other we had gone on a
few dates and like like we'd gone down
on each other and like he'd finger me
and stuff and I'd give him a [ __ ] so
that we've done all that foreplay stuff
already so then this night it was uh so
I had snuck out of my house and he snuck
me into his house aka a really nice
mansion and so like anyway I was in his
room and we kind of started trying to do
things and I don't know why I thought
this would be a good idea but I was like
maybe if I'm on top it'll hurt less
don't don't do that I it was so painful
that I was like oh my god it was just
like trying to like lower myself it was
a bad like the weight of your body's
working against a good idea so but
anyway so then we ended up doing doing
it and then it was super painful and
then like you know he was wearing a
condom so afterwards like he went to the
bathroom he flushed him because he was
paranoid I was gonna steal his he was
[ __ ] weird we weren't even boyfriend
and his burger yeah yeah like oh I can't
be having this brave girl and I'm like
have a baby with you're even an NFL star
no one's after its sperm and then it's
kind of sad like okay this kind of get
sad but later on like years later I
found out he did end up having a kid and
the mom left him with a kid so he's like
a single dad that was yeah that's kind
of sad anyway so then but yeah so then
that happened and I was at his house for
like five hours like it took an eternity
for us to get this [ __ ] going but then
afterwards he ended it was like sneaking
me out and then drove me back home and
then the next day he was like were you
even a virgin
I was like yes you [ __ ] [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] like weren't you there the
whole time it was painful yeah and he
was like well you didn't bleed and I was
like such an [ __ ] so I was just like
whatever man
I don't know why but I still ended up
talking to hanging out with this guy
even after that and and then he let me
borrow his phone for something and I
remember looking at a photo and there
was this picture of white sheets with
like a tiny red stain and I was like
what is this and he's like that's your
blood so I guess you were telling the
truth you were ever I'm like the white
picture of the blood see like yeah he
was jacked off to that blood stain why
have you been with every single guy
you've been with this been strange as
hell - well I mean I'm married so I I
feel like I need to defend them yeah man
you guys are making me sweat yeah I
think we should put a little bit of
native on your strong little native is a
fantastic brain of deodorant that I
actually keep one in my desk I keep one
at home and I keep one in my brand-new
car we have my favorite which is the
coconut vanilla they have a lot of other
sense as well does my personal favorite
smell like a cocoa butter baby but
mostly for I don't know if anyone else
has like problems with perspiration that
I did for years and years and years I
always use any kind of clinical strength
deodorant well I started using native
because we're working with them and I
had all these native deodorants I kept
one on my desk I had one at home and
sometimes I would get worried when I got
to work I was like oh I'm using I'm not
using the clinical strength but I would
never sweat yeah literally all day I am
a person that is needed clinical
strength deodorant their entire life and
I've used native never sweat seriously
it works
people love native if you go online
you'll see that they have over 8,000
five-star reviews you don't know yeah
you know when you see a good review I'm
like all right sounds good um there's
let there's simple ingredients and
there's you know there's something for
everyone as far as the sense there's
lavender rose cucumber and mint
eucalyptus and man you know you can cue
cumber one smell like a spa room good as
well as a few limited edition seasonal
sense please give me a candy cane scent
is peppermint if you guys want to try
native free-verse 20% off of your
purchase get a couple you getting 20%
off the hold you'll go to native
deodorant calm and use the promo code
b-tch 20 during checkout once again for
20% off your first purchase visit native
deodorant calm and use the promo code bt
CH 20 support us get your discount and
stop sweating girl mmhmm yeah yeah that
was really sweaty that night too
yeah my first boyfriend he was a sweater
too
I thought that all people did that but
then I was like oh it's like having a
winter coat all the time your first time
having a penis inside of your vagina
actually don't want to be a downer so oh
no I want to talk about what I wish I
had done okay yeah I you know it's kind
of crazy because even so now I like I'm
sexually open like you know I talk to
you guys all the time about you know my
personal life and my losing my virginity
experience was god what a waste
um what a waste for a lot of women I
think it's wise up being quite
disappointing yeah I mean it's better
that you kind of lower expectations to
if you are original is then I do hear
like once like you have really high
expectations for losing your virginity
and it doesn't mean it's kinda like that
Paris syndrome like you hear about when
people end up going to Paris and then
they end up getting very severely
depressed because it's not as good as it
yet it was it's like maybe just don't
expect like perfect perfect experience
well I I think that it it was it's it's
a very it's actually for me and I don't
know about other people it was actually
a very
emotional experience I felt a lot of
regret afterwards okay and not even
because of like my Christian guilt but
because of who I shared that moment with
and that person was really nobody really
nobody oh she didn't have feelings or
anything um I did that person didn't
have feelings for me hey girl I think I
almost feel like they stole my like
manipulation I think a lot of people can
relate to that that's exactly the story
I feel like happens too and when you go
through that and I think you had that
expectation cuz you heard about people
that lost it like so romantically and
you know you wait till marriage and
someone that you really loved it it was
something like that and then it's like
oh [ __ ] that was it like I wasted mine
and I think that's common so it's really
good that you're sharing that and I mean
like in it and in the regret didn't come
from like and you guys know I've shared
a lot of times I grew up in a very very
strict Christian household and I think a
part of me when I was younger I like
when I was a teenager so I was like very
rebellious you know when you're like 16
you're like [ __ ] the world yeah I think
part of me was rebelling against
Christianity so I didn't value it as
much and I'm not saying like value your
purity or something I'm saying value
this thing for yourself if you're a
person like me that's very sensitive and
emotional you know that is a special
moment and I would I would like even the
first guy that I dated like piece of
[ __ ] I kind of at least wish it was
something with somebody that cared about
me you know so it's like I don't know I
really don't know how to describe it but
it's it's an it's con its past like it's
kind of whatever and you you keep it you
keep it going but I still have any
regrets or like feel like oh I wish I
could take that moment back or is it
kind of like that was a learning
experience I don't know it's really
interesting because I feel like I feel
like you know Christianity aside like
yeah Christianity tells you that this is
supposed to be this pure thing this this
thing that you hold on to but I I i
think that they tell you that for
reasons other than why you really should
and i still don't even know what that is
because i never got to share that
experience with somebody special
i don't know what it could have been
like
could have morphed my perception of sex
for the rest of my life sure but
unfortunately I shared that moment with
somebody where there was no pleasure
there was no emotional connection even
though I really liked this person they
didn't really like me they they had just
like almost manipulated me into like oh
yeah I really like you like we could
totally date like I'll you know blah
blah and you know they they like
afterwards spread a bunch of rumors
about me oh yeah it was really bad and I
had to change high school like sexually
oh [ __ ] yeah so yeah it definitely was
so I ended up switching schools after
that and I think I think not only not
only do I wish that it was like somebody
other than that person I just wished
that I had maybe share that moment with
somebody that cared about me yeah and
sometimes when you're a young girl and
just looking for love you don't see that
and when you don't value that thing and
when you think oh only Christianity is
telling me this I'm gonna rebel like you
you're just like this is trash this
doesn't mean anything but um it does
means I mean as a human it's still it's
still a valuable like first time first
time experience yeah and I genuinely
believe that your first time experience
with sex can change your perception for
the rest of life on it and that might
also be why you know when I grew up I
didn't enjoy sex I didn't yeah orgasm
for a long time it really kind of
screwed me up I was like this is a
complete waste because my first time was
treated like nothing I wonder like you
know how we have therapy like we've
discussed that we've both done therapy
on like going back and kind of hugging
and like being there for our childhood
self like our six-year-old cellphone
what if there's some sort of like thing
you do maybe with someone you do love if
you're in a relationship with them to
like kind of redo that first section why
I was like that's mad wack but then I'm
like wait a minute I think like
emotionally like yeah I'm feeling yeah I
think so um but yeah it definitely it
definitely warped my perception of sex
because this person taught me that my
body and my virginity and you know any
of that was not valuable it
mean anything like you know and that
that said something about myself and
when you're you know 16 and you're still
figuring yourself out and you don't know
who you are you kind of just take hints
from what the world throws at you right
and when the world throws at you that
your body is not important then you're
like oh I guess that meant nothing to
them and you know it's a really
emotional thing I and I still remember
like after that happened I ran away from
home for two days so like I think it
definitely really really really screwed
me up like I'm so heartbroken for
sixteen-year-old those for her right now
I mean my my I guess it to change the
like it was two cops I'm not good at
hosting I don't have a great transition
from that I value your anyway you guys
know who I lost my virginity to because
in the group chat a while back I sent
you guys oh yeah I've seen the key so I
didn't know this but now I went back on
Facebook and for some reason I started
looking up all the guys that I've dated
before in my life and so the guy lost my
virginity to was my very first boyfriend
in high school so we dated like almost
immediately starting freshman year all
the way through maybe soft warrior 2 I
think I was like a year and some change
or something like that but so I was a
cheerleader freshman year and there was
all the cheerleaders so like most of
them were freshmen on the team that I
was on and then a whole group of us were
all dating the junior basketball stars
of the team so it was like all the
basketball stuff they were the varsity
okay they were they were juniors but
they were on the varsity okay there was
seniors on varsity too obviously but
these were all the junior varsity so
it's kind of funny because like me and
my friends were all dating like the same
guys and their friends from the team
such a total like high school movie it
kind of got recreated later where we're
all working at a company
yeah but yeah so we dated for a whole
year and we would like everyone at
school newest like as the make-out
couple because everywhere we went we
would be making out for hours and hours
and hours and accurate title for you
guys right we we had this one friend and
he would drive us around everywhere like
he was like the one guy that had a car
that we would hang out with and we would
be in the backseat like he was our taxi
driver and we would just be making out
for hours and hours and hours going to
every party making out everywhere so we
were together for a whole year and then
finally summer before my sophomore year
we decided it was time so I was actually
still 14 oh so I guess maybe I was young
in school because I didn't turn Jesus I
didn't turn 15 until the summer before
sophomore year started yeah so I would
have to I was just a few weeks from
being 15 years old but technically I was
still 14 so I lost my virginity at 14
but it was actually pretty cool because
I did love I felt like I loved him I
felt like he loved me but things were
kind of starting to wrap up because he
was going into a senior year and I felt
like less important like he was already
kind of mentally checking out now versus
when we first started dating he was
still kind of mentally in high school
because he had just started a junior
year so I think I kind of a part of me
did it too because I was like oh I think
he's kind of pulling away now cuz he's
gonna be a senior and he's gonna be
leaving and he's gonna be leaving me so
there was a little bit of insecurity
there for why I did that but overall I
feel like we both still love each other
but the actual experience now it was
very sad I think he put it in like a
couple of times it hurts so bad and then
he just got up and went to the bathroom
so this whole thing was like 10 seconds
whoa I mean he went into the bathroom I
have no idea if he came or not he was in
the bathroom for a solid like 15 minutes
no I was still sitting there with my rot
now raw vagina that just got yeah like
ripped apart out just for 15 minutes
just sitting in his room like is he
coming back like are we still gonna do
it like what's happening and the shit's
in the middle of it
but he was huge he was like one of the
biggest guys have ever been with she's
to lose my virginity to that yeah it's
already difficult but it sucked because
like he because he left me there the
whole time like while he was in bathroom
and I was like what is he doing and I
was like is he jacking off or like maybe
he came already and then he was trying
to get it back up but like not in front
of me I couldn't figure out what was
happening but then eventually he just
came out like 20 minutes later while
still laying there you know like awkward
as hell and he's just like do you want
to go to the corner store and get a soda
and I was like okay so we just like
started driving around and like hanging
out doing other stuff pretending like
that didn't happen after that I think
maybe a couple of times but it kind of
ended sort of after that but I remember
I didn't have sex for like a whole year
after that because I was no longer in a
relationship but then I so I lost my
virginity a couple like I had sex a
couple of times it was so bad like there
was nothing good and then I'd have sex
again for a whole year or maybe almost
two years like I remember I just like
lost it and then did nothing for me
because like that guy like he wasn't
technically my boyfriend but then right
after we had lost our virginity to each
other I asked him because I really liked
this guy and so I asked him I'm like hey
do you want to be like
boyfriend/girlfriend now and then he was
like wait so you he's like you slept
with me so you can trick me to being
your boyfriend no but usually it's the
other way around like usually it's like
oh the guy gets with the girl to get
hurt like exactly but I'm like no so
then we had only had sex that one like
only one time and then after that I
start like I met someone else and like I
really like this other guy he actually
liked me back and he treated me right
and then I guess this first guy he had
hit me up and he was like really drunk
one night he was like I [ __ ] up I
really wanted to be with you I just I
was like too scared to want to be with
you or something and he's like do you
want to be my girlfriend now and I'm
like nah dude
guys are so done yeah learning curve for
sure yeah okay so I feel like I had guys
um I had this one guy that so he lived
down the street from me and literally
two blocks over
and I I kind of liked him for a while
like he was tall he was like really into
metal like I thought he was pretty high
friends that cute popular all this [ __ ]
and he lived on the street for me and we
we would like Hank we would hang out a
lot with his friends and then there was
one day were like he was trying to [ __ ]
me and I think we were maybe like 19 or
20 yeah and I was like dude I was like
we've kind of been talking but like
because of my previous experience I was
like I'm not in relationship I'm
interested I was like no I'm not I'm not
gonna [ __ ] you and he was like but I
want you to be my girlfriend and and I
was like oh you want me to be your
girlfriend line and sinker and so we
ended up hooking up we didn't go all the
way but we ended up hooking up and I was
just like okey now you're my boyfriend
like straight up like we've been talking
for like three or four months and so
like I thought it was a little fast but
I liked him I was down I was like
whatever so I was like okay I guess her
day now or whatever so later on that day
I go home and he was like oh come back
over tonight for dinner he was like oh
my dad's out of town like we'll make
dinner a bla bla bla and and like he was
a smoker so I remember I had gone to the
gas station and I picked him up a pack
of cigarettes before I came over and I
got called him cuz I was gonna come over
and he never answered and then I call
him like we didn't like buck but we like
hooked up you know and like then I
called him again
no it's like two and a half hours later
like I saw him a text no answer
completely went cold on me and so I'm
like I'm so glad I didn't [ __ ] that dude
and so then like I mentioned this in a
cheating episode this is the same guy
that who had the photo of his wife and
his child in the picture that like deep
like messaged me ten years later on
Facebook and was like damn I should have
had you when I had the chance
so [ __ ] gross and like these dudes
are out there and they like they will
manipulate you or at least try to you
and having sex with them I think I just
got the dirtiest yeah did you guys not
had any of these [ __ ] I had one
but um you know what it would break bad
habits and so a lot of people it's new
as a fitness app for first of all so
it's like gonna help you not only focus
on like you're not the focus isn't about
losing weight or even like getting
muscle mass or whatever it's more about
breaking habits you know bad habits that
you have formed and so I like noon
because they guide you through not only
a physical goal I like better self-care
confidence in clothing more energy
overall glow but also the psychological
stuff like help making healthy choices
like having self-worth have like better
mood staff controlling anxiety and
stress and then um one thing I didn't
take into account on why I may not have
been hitting my goals are the social
aspects of feeling like you need to like
a drink to blend in or like needing to
eat something I have something that's
keeping you busy because maybe you have
social anxiety I did so new really
helped to like learn to resist
temptations when you go out and be
comfortable in social environments and
Trust in your ability to make good
choices so all of those things happen
through their courses where they like
you sign up they ask you what your
personal goals are and then they kind of
give you a lesson which with each day
like something to take with you on your
day to keep in mind so that when you're
thinking of making an unhealthy choice
you're already psychologically in this
zone of like no I'm not going to make
that choice today so you don't have to
change it all in one day small steps
take big progress so sign up for your
trial today at noon and oo-whee today at
noon and oom comm slash b tch and you
can yeah you get a free trial visit
pneumo
slash b tch to start your trial today
that's my slash b tch
the last weight-loss program you'll ever
need try try it sounds amazing
yeah go I got 10 minutes a day exercise
programs too which is really convenient
to your schedule yeah but yeah we're
talking about a guy yes so my first
boyfriend that I lost my virginity to
really sweet story right like we were
dating for a year which is kind of like
you're like married in high school being
together for a year long and I was a
year older so it wasn't like the thing
that you had where he checked out it was
like oh like we're in this together so I
went from that with a guy that like
really cared about me and I thought I
was gonna be together with for a long
time we ended up breaking up because of
other issues drug related issues but
like that was that was more like sad um
then I went straight to like at that
point so I had now entered the rest of
my junior year I was like second half of
junior year and I got my braces off you
know I started like losing weight I was
really overweight throughout the first
half of high school and guys didn't
really pay attention to me before but
now all of a sudden I was single and I
looked way different and this popular
guy was like hitting on me and I didn't
even know he was hitting on me at all
like people had to tell me like oh he's
hitting girls like and then I got really
nervous because I was like well I'm in a
different class human because you're
over here in the popular group and I was
like punk rock emo like over here were
very like [ __ ] you popular people but
then this guy was paying attention to me
and I thought he was really cute he
reminded me of Topher Grace who I really
liked boom that 70s show that died oh
yeah and so I kind of just like
projected all that and the fact that
someone in this class was paying
attention to me and he was kind of funny
and stuff yeah whatever
so we started like he has started asked
me to hang out with him and we just go
to his house and we would watch TV in
his room and make out and it was like oh
my god like I can't believe this
happened so fast cuz before was just a
crush to get over my ex and then it
evolved into that and then I finally
asked him after like a month of doing
this I was like are we like boyfriend
and girlfriend
I was like I don't know how popular
people do it yeah maybe do it a way
different way than me so he's like yeah
and so oh my god and then um we so we
had sex cuz I was like yeah boy for new
girlfriend let's try let's try this yeah
and so then we started having sex and I
like after the third time he started
getting more distant like stopped asking
me to come over
stop asking me to like hang out I could
barely get a hold of him he would never
answer his phone before we were texting
all the time and stuff and then um he
broke up with me through his friend
because I had asked his best friend like
what's up like I haven't been able to
talk to this guy in over a week
and we're supposed to be boyfriend and
girlfriend and and the guy it was like
yeah I didn't want to do this but and he
pulls out a list and lists off all of
the things wrong with me so he said like
hey Harry I thought you're gonna like
say something but like mature like
doesn't know what she wants it was like
because I was really nervous around him
because I wasn't sure if the things that
I thought were funny or like the same
things that popular people think are
funny you know I was like I felt not in
my my class yeah so I was just very like
nervous around him and so he was like
yeah she's [ __ ] weird she always
makes these weird jokes and stuff and I
got like really my head and the one
thing that really stuck out it was he
said I wasn't girly enough because um I
was like punk rock right so but why
would you say he know you did it
did he have you guys open the whole time
like why did you do that why did you can
hook up with me then but um yeah he was
like he just really liked but like girly
girls and his ex was like cheerleader
girl and he likes like how she did her
makeup and we're perfume and lake wore
high heels like all that stuff instead
of being like oh [ __ ] that guy this is
who I am it got me so in my head I was
scared to talk to people I was scared to
like
interact I wanted to be all the things
that he broke up with me for so I
started reading all the cosmopolitan
magazine's I started like this what
girls are into like what are they do
like they do their nails okay I could
try to paint my nails okay and then I
was like using the perfume samples I'm
like that's what she names went really
far in yeah I was it made me hate myself
I hated who I was I hated that like I
wasn't cool like I like I wasn't like oh
yeah and the idiot friend actually read
it to her yeah was he actually kind of
had a crush on me but that I figured out
later and it couldn't happen because we
had already dated really trying figure
out like even as a teenager what was the
intent oh I just wanted to [ __ ] me so I
was like why would he get with me and so
it was like he just wanted to [ __ ] me
because I had a bubble butt and like he
wanted a pop yes
and so he broke up with me two weeks
before prom yeah took his ex-girlfriend
to prom and I went on this mission to
like show up hot so prom yeah and
whatever it works but the night just
down to pizzas after like went home sad
crying but um yeah like it was he was
actually you know blessing in disguise
because I ended up being like the first
couple of stand-up bits that I wrote
later in my life when I after I had gone
through would come out the other end and
been like [ __ ] that guy I started
writing stand-up and that was like a an
outlet for me yeah all things happen for
a reason
[ __ ] bad guys beause I feel so bad I
must say there's rhinox a feeling it
doesn't get said enough if you are under
18 and you should be 18 to watch the
show but if I don't know maybe you have
a friend that's tough look they need to
say this more if you're dating somebody
when you're like still in high school
that is not your husband that is a
lesson no it really is like like do not
make it more than it is that is a lesson
point-blank boy people like Steve where
his parents got married like they were
they were there first and then they got
married like he grew up thinking that
yeah right and he wanted a wife since he
was like June
my brother's name is Stephen also and he
married his high-school sweetheart and
they're still married he's the he's the
5% though but I feel like even when we
were younger they sold that to us as
very cute and is packaged really nicely
and we wanted to believe it and it's
just really not it's really just not
true for the most part you know it's
know who you are yeah yeah yeah and I
think you know what I like I told you
guys about some of the shitty guys it's
really not even the tip of the iceberg I
didn't even dip into like how awful it
was but you know what and I'm not saying
I blame the younger version of myself
but something that I've learned is that
I was so insecure even at fifteen it
like radiated off of me that I hated
myself that I was in pain that I didn't
know who I was and people pick up on
that they absolutely pick up on that and
so sometimes you feel when you're
growing up as though they don't like me
but it's not that they don't like you
maybe people don't like this shell that
you've encased yourself in of insecurity
that you don't even realize that you're
showing off its just your defense
mechanism and Pete I'm so sure that
these guys could tell from me that I was
insecure and depressed and nobody wants
to date that girl it's like a
self-fulfilling prophecy it is very much
a self-fulfilling prophecy and so you
know I also would really like say
strongly for anybody if you know if you
are interested in a guy and suddenly it
doesn't work out and you really feel
like you're the problem like it may not
be you who you really are it may be this
image of yourself that you're putting
out whether it's intentional or on
purpose it could be the image you're
putting out as clearly false you know it
is and you don't realize that they pick
up on it and it could also be that the
image you're putting out is insecure
because nobody unfortunately is
attracted to an insecure person unless
they're planning to prey on you yeah
right and sure there's that old saying
that's like people treat you how you
treat yourself yes you already think low
of yourself people subconsciously pick
that up yeah that's true I definitely
had I had an experience I don't want to
say it's quite like Nicki's but sort of
so there was no list involved I wasn't
reading my face I wasn't actually dating
this guy but like so the second guy I
had sex with in high school he was they
okay so he was a part of the same group
of guys that was like the junior group
that we were dating when were freshmen
but now I'm going into my sophomore year
I think they were seniors now and this
was the more popular guy this was like
homecoming king like everyone probably
top three guys at the school right and
so I started sleeping with him on the
side I because I after I'd lost my
virginity to my first boyfriend who I
was with for a year and then I was like
nothing was going on for a year so
towards the end of this the sophomore
year now I bagged them like one of the
most popular guys in school and I
honestly didn't realize that I was doing
it because of insecurity but I think I
was and I just felt like oh look I'm I'm
young rise in the ranks now look at me
now but he was kind of using me to like
because he was kind of publicly starting
to like date other girls girls that were
prettier than me had more money than me
and all of that but then he would be the
one to call me after the house parties
and I thought oh we have something like
secret and special but it's really like
I was the less popular the poor the you
know the poor one that so happened to
kind of weasel her way into the popular
party yeah so I was just like the secret
and I and I enjoyed it for a little
while but then after a while my my ex so
the boyfriend that I had in my freshman
year he was like do you not realize what
he's doing like he's like kind of
courting he's like pretty blonde like
perfect big-titty girls like in front of
the other the school but like he's
hiding you in the back and like having
sex with you like instead of you know
with the pretty girls who aren't willing
to put out and I was just like holy [ __ ]
it was a nice ex-boyfriend I mean yeah
so like it was definitely a learning
experience like because I thought that I
was like oh I'm so cool look at me like
I bagged this guy and it's our secret in
it but then after what I thought about
I'm like I was just being kind of used
and like it wasn't good yeah and it's
hard to see that from like an outsider's
perspective when you're in it because
you're like you you want to feel special
you want to believe what you yeah want
to believe you want to believe that he's
like into you and like you're something
special yeah but but I was the one that
was willing to put out cuz I already
lost my virginity and a lot of the other
like super preppy like pretty like rich
girls like they weren't hot they weren't
putting out yet you know what it means
like he with you he wanted to be like
with like starting to date them in
public but you know getting laid on the
side with the the brown-haired like I
feel like there's something about like
when you're kind of the secret I think
that there's some kind of appeal that
you're like oh at the end of this I
might get him yeah you know it doesn't
work it doesn't work it was kind of like
that with the popular guys too because
we were even in classes together and we
wouldn't hang out during class like it
wasn't I couldn't just go up to him and
hold his hand like but if you guys were
in class together he could like
completely ignore you but at one point
he may look at you and say oh and you'd
be like I got it yeah and like no one
else gets to know about it no one else
knows we're doing like he could like
send you a text and be like you look
really cute today and you're in like it
just fills your heart but you don't
because you live for the crumbs you're
like they ignore me so much that when
they send that little crumb you're like
oh he likes me no you know so we're
talking about virginity right I
remembered an experience I had right
before I actually did lose my virginity
oh it looks here and and so okay I was a
pretty bad girl in high school I would
ditch a lot and we'd go to like these
ditch parties right in the morning we
were drinking that early like we were
drinking yeah I was bad anyway so then
so at one of these ditch parties all my
girlfriends and I we all went to this
guy's house and this guy he was slightly
older but he lived like with his parents
or whatever but they weren't there and
so he had his guy friends come over and
the oldest guy in the room was his
whatever I'm not going to say his name
but anyway like he they all had
nicknames and stuff so this dude he he
was like trying to court me and stuff
and by then I was already pretty damn
drunk and listen I have a lot of these
very bad like don't get drunk in public
and take care of yourselves story I have
a lot of these but this for this one
though
in particular this dude we started
making out in the bedroom and and it was
so ridiculous because this guy the guy's
house he had like a twin size bed and I
think that was like his parents bed and
but in the same room that was my bed
there was a bunk bed it was like three
beds in one room Oh weird it was really
weird and so me and this the oldest guy
in the room we were in like the twin
size bed and then my friend was in one
of the bunk beds and then the other
friend was on top of the bump so there's
literally three couples making out yeah
in the same room and hella drunk and at
one point and by the way I was on my
period and I had a tampon it and at one
point this dude was like hey so um like
do you want to like you know and I was
just like I'm a virgin no like I don't
know I literally met this dude that same
day and then so um and he was just like
no come on like let's just you know like
just the tip and I was like dude I have
a tampon it like there's no way you're
know like no but I was again I was
really inebriated this [ __ ] just
took advantage a lot and so he actually
did strike try to stick his tip in like
with my tampon in oh yeah know that it
was there no he literally felt it he was
like oh yeah you weren't lying
oh yeah it goes in and I'm like yeah
dude I was so drunk and I was like fifty
six fifteen sixteen yeah and this dude
was like the heat was morning know did
he stick you saying like he was like 20
or some [ __ ] like yeah that seems to be
like a common thread maybe in like
Mexican culturally I can at least for as
long as far as I know in Mexican culture
young girls really find it attractive to
look up to like you big guy like older
guys and like these older guys tend to
get really young girls like that's just
the norm like 14 or 15 16 more like 23
24 yeah yeah I mean it's not too far
like I can get how that could culturally
be acceptable it's I mean it's I know
it's not great because at 16 you're way
different than at 24 but yeah
these guys are so immature that you have
to get younger girls anyway so then this
guy he tries to do that and then like I
push him off cuz I was like what the
[ __ ]
I said no like said it was his dick out
and like trying to go in yeah so we were
under the covers that's like we're
making out under the covers and like he
literally like he'd just I forgot what I
was wearing but like he somehow got up
in there and put his like little tip
like the mushroom head did not go in the
hole like I said like there's no way
he's gonna go in but like I don't know
like that's what I think about that
situation I'm like yeah did that count
I think we hung out like a couple more
times after that but like that was the
only time that I like we were even
kissing and [ __ ] and I'll just like why
yeah I feel like I put myself in a lot
of dangerous situations as a naive
[ __ ] teenager like so much so where
I'm like I don't want to have kids cuz
they're gonna probably do they don't
live so we I ditched school a couple
that was a good girl but I started
hanging with the wrong yeah we did
school a couple times are out lunch like
I guess I wouldn't really be considered
ditching because it would be lunchtime
then we try to make it back before lunch
ended but sometimes it would go into a
fifth period but my friend was dating
yeah my friend was the bad girl and she
was dating this guy who lived like along
the back end of the school and his
brother was this older dude who was like
25 and he would like smoke everyone out
with his bong the other way that's the
only time I ever did a bong hit and I
got way too stoned and wait a minute I
cannot smoke marijuana a lot but since
she would be making out with the brother
I was left with the older brother and I
wouldn't think he was giving me lots of
attention and I was like sitting on his
lap and this was before I started dating
my first boyfriend so
I was completely virgin like didn't have
any experience really with making out
like I made out maybe twice before then
and so it became a regular thing we're
like they would make out and we would
make out and who's 25 oh yeah and I was
14 oh I didn't think of it that way
either was just like well I'm doing cool
kids yeah so many people outside of high
school while I was in high school and
looking back I think you were so cool so
we found out later he started like as
deers progressed I stopped talking that
guy after I got a boyfriend like I just
like splintered off from that group I
never really hung out with them again
but I found out later that he started
dating this girl who was 15 at our
school like they were like
boyfriend/girlfriend and some crazy [ __ ]
went down where they would like do drugs
together and he would like hold the gun
to her head well as part of their she's
like no it's like part of our like role
play but it was like a real gun loaded I
don't know I didn't ask and I was like
wow I literally dodged a bullet
ICP and smokes pot all day and like in
like a garage apartment not ICP but
that's not too far off it was like yeah
like underground hip-hop like some like
Sage Francis some I don't know any of
that
some like atmosphere do you know okay
forgot about that until you brought that
up with the older guy thing because I go
[ __ ] it like that whole file opened up
oh my oh my god these times I took that
well I can't dress teenager little me
that's gonna come out so you guys know
what else I did for the first time in
high school what did you do I mean this
I guess I suck I did feel like I was a
virgin even though I had lost my
virginity so everything that I did for
like the first couple years was just so
like she's kind of like oh my god I mean
but like for the first time in high
school I made out with two guys at the
same time in
your tongues are like oh my god outside
of a house party right I think I might
have been a junior at this point so one
of them had already graduated but it was
the guy that I was hooking up with the
popular guy the one that I that was kind
of using me a little bit so like he had
already graduated high school but so he
was like I guess a senior and call it or
sorry freshman in college now but he
would come back for the house parties
because a lot of the juniors and seniors
would come back home at like during
breaks at college or whatever in house
party with the people that were still in
high school so like we're all there so I
grabbed him and then we get into the
truck of his friend who was also
graduated high school so two [ __ ]
losers at this point right and we were
making out and you know what's funny as
I remember 50 cent
it's your that birthday song or whatever
yo shawty what is the line like I don't
have I don't have sex I don't make love
I have sex or something like that
however that line goes I think about the
two of those guys because that song was
looking playing is into like having to
do I think I really didn't care for the
other guy like cuz I had it like I guess
a history with you the other guy the
first guy the popular one that I was
kind of [ __ ] around with so I really
liked him and I kinda wanted to bag him
again but then like his friend being
there was just like kind of this really
cool thing that we did also I was like
oh my god okay we were doing this way
but I need to know with me making know
okay so yeah just like a sixteen year
old Jesse so they're like I hope you
guys if they started making out they're
probably been really [ __ ] cool but no
the guy one guy was in the driver's seat
the other guy was in the passenger seat
and it was like a big truck like you
know I'm from Texas it was big truck and
so I'm sitting in the middle because
it's like a huge like like seat so
there's plenty of space and so like I'm
like sitting then I like make out with
this guy while the other guys like kind
of like rubbing me like oh my Clinton
stuff or like trying to get me started
then I like turn around to this guy I
start making out after all I was like
okay the guy that I actually liked like
that I already had sex with before like
he kisses better
he smells better he's taste better
everything's better about him so
I was trying to figure out how to get
out of it after a while because I was
like okay now I'm like going back and
forth I'm like I really am NOT into this
one and then he starts touching me I'm
kind of like no I just kind of what the
first one like I just want this one so
that was kind of my first yeah I guess
it's my only time ever like doing
anything with two guys so when you guys
got into the truck or was just like
let's hang I share I think it was like
we we were gonna go somewhere maybe go
to the next house party or something so
he just turned on the truck and like
we're listening to music we're kind of
talking it's like before like we're like
you know like when you're getting ready
to go somewhere sometimes you're just
kind of in the car like doing things or
like kind of [ __ ] around for a minute
before you actually leave to go
somewhere so we kind of just it just
took longer to leave and then I guess
that 50 cent song really got to me you
know it really turned me on for some
reason I was down I'm just surprised I
wonder if they like had thought about it
or planned to do the guy was trying to
pawn you off on his friend oh yeah I
don't I don't know because I wound up
actually we I think his friend cuz his
friend was the one with the truck so we
went somewhere else and I think I wound
up leaving with him and just went to the
other guy but first guys house anyway so
I think if he's trying to pawn me off he
wouldn't have taken me home I think he
was just kinda like mine I think he was
like it was like okay this girl's freaky
I'll take her back but yeah I don't know
it was crazy but I I just yeah I don't
my Christian guilt alarm bells are
ringing right now and it's like sin
sinner shame I don't know shame actually
we should do that again if anybody okay
with making out with me with and it was
an additional man in the room let me
know and you want them to make out
though - right but if they will I'm down
there's like a weird bit of like
admiration for you and that because I'm
like wow I can't believe she's doing
that but it's so funny because like you
guys just made out and I'm like oh like
I've had like such I don't know I feel
like I've had really positive
experiences with sex and like I don't
know if it was just like my cuz even if
people were kind of like maybe the
popular guy was kind of using me and
people let me know like oh he's kind of
using your whatever like still the sex
part of it was still so positive in my
eyes so like even making out two guys at
one time like even if they were talking
about me behind my back or anything I'm
like I don't even know I was like it was
so fun like I just enjoyed it you know
that's true even when the popular guy
was taking advantage of me I didn't know
in the moment yeah I was not I didn't
feel like he was being mean yeah it was
just like we were both having consensual
sex and then later he hurt me yeah
things wise I'm lucky though because
unlike Bo's no one ever spread bad
rumors about me or like talked trash
about me or like my reputation was
ruined by any of this like I went to a
really small school to my entire school
was like 200 people so I whole school
was like 200 people maybe 250 max I
think my graduating class was like 75
Dan so each other it was tiny like no
one gave a [ __ ] though I we were all
just like chill yeah so okay so like I
didn't expand too much on mine and like
coming back in hot with a Debbie Downer
but I think it's also like kind of like
a like a thing so the school that I went
to I had two best friends we were a trio
and guys trios are always off balance
they are always always always off
balance and the girl that was kind of
the leader of our pact was like a total
narcissist even now this girl's like
really weird still really weird um and I
didn't pick up on certain things like
she a lot of guys liked her she was a
year younger but the sophomores really
really liked her and there was a group
of really popular guys maybe like seven
or eight of them and she would come over
during lunch and sit on one guy's lap
and then our other friend would kind of
stand next to her and she would tell me
I had to go sit in another table and
then one time she made me sit on the
floor and like I did not like register
and that's kind of like abuse that was
happening and so she was dating
guy from the group another girl was kind
of talking to different guys from the
group and to kind of fit in I started
talking to one of the guys in the group
which is the guy I lost my virginity to
and it's like they gave me the stupidest
guy like he had really long hair he
[ __ ] probably I don't probably
smelled bad I don't know like his face
was okay but he was like he had a
stutter like he was like the like he was
kind of the joke of the whole group and
they go bad for that guy yeah and so
he's getting roasted like kind of become
relevant in his own group he just made a
really really really awful rumor up
about me oh I don't think that for him
anymore about me and I mean it spread
everywhere like to seniors to like
everyone I had people leaving myspace
comments like calling me this really
awful name and like I had to like move
to a different high school and I spent I
spent periods like during lunch period
eating lunch in the bathroom because
both of my friends would like or just
sitting in the bathroom stalls I would
go into bathroom stall and look and I
would stay there for 30 minutes yeah and
then like or I would skip classes that I
had with those girls that were my
friends and they'd call me after school
like hey are you coming over and I'd be
like yeah coming over you know like that
was literally like my high school
experience like it was awful it like
really [ __ ] ruined sex for me it
really like rage would you were you in
um we were I think I think we're fresh
no not freshmen we were sophomores we
were sophomores yeah and so no these
guys must have been juniors um and so I
ended up having to leave and that was
just the first high school I left for my
way I went to four different high
schools like like yeah we have to do a
high school episode because I did [ __ ]
I'm sure you guys oh yeah I got a lot of
high school memories yeah
are they good yeah mine are I really
don't understand like why high school
kids are so [ __ ] mean about sex stuff
because it's like everyone's going in
that direction like everyone's just a
projection is their virginity about to
go off to college like why why your
girls so mean to each other yeah
it is guys thing to like prey on like
they can lie about what happened in the
bedroom or they can lie about your body
or they can lie about something that
happened and no one really knows and
then people in high school with their
kids and they're just like yeah that's
true haha at least it's not me yeah they
spread it like wildfire and they believe
it I got like they're they're kind of
like the whole like Twitterverse right
now or it's like get the attention off
of me like in case I get a mistake like
I'm gonna put all the attention on this
girl over here and just watch her get
crushed
and it and it's still it's still
happening like in high schools you know
I'm sorry for if and if anyone's still
in high school like oh it's gonna get
better I promise it's College happens in
colleges too or like girls you know get
drunk and have like a bad night we're
like they didn't really do anything
wrong but next thing you know some guy
is like oh four of us [ __ ] ER and it's
a no no you did it and then yeah you
know probably it's even worse with like
everyone having a cell phone and social
media yeah can you imagine being in high
school and everyone can see how many
Instagram followers you have and that's
all that matters oh my god so much more
insecure than it already was I can't
already was that way I guess so bad for
kids in high school today oh my god that
just really hit me too yeah imagining
like dealing with social media and then
see it everything I mean I was in high
school with MySpace and like top eight
was like oh my god are you on that
person's top eight or who's in your
talking minor but like now it's like
insane dude there was using about social
media when I was in high school I don't
think like it literally did not matter
we didn't have it we didn't have cell
phones we don't have nothing when I was
in high school so I just can't even
imagine yeah or like in one thing that I
I'm Mike I feel like this happened this
actually happened to a girl when I was
in college just or not college when I
was in my senior year this is when I
message wasn't even I think it was just
SMS I remember somebody there was a
really nerdy girl in school and she had
accidentally sent a nude to somebody and
she was like 17 and people started
passing it around you know I can't
imagine you know young girls matin you
know taking a photo or doing something
and it gets passed around because now
every
has a cellphone yeah everybody has a
cellphone you know it's crazy needs to
have snake Kelly Rowland music video
where she was texting but it was used to
have to put messages and pagers like
where you could like spell out words
with numbers oh yeah that was our form
of text numbers yeah yeah I mean high
school I mean high schools rough thing
we do a little thing on high school I
think anybody who is going through a
rough time when they're younger like
under in your 20s or so you are learning
and growing so so so so much and I hate
to say it but everyone that [ __ ]
peaked in high school cuz I think we've
all seen it they didn't have to learn
these skills they got by just by being
hot popular rich whatever it was and now
suddenly at 23 24 they have to learn how
to be a functioning person whereas a lot
of us have been beat down in our youth
and you live through it and it becomes a
major strength yeah so if you're going
through anything
shitty write it down like figure it out
solve it and keep going cuz you're gonna
turn into a dope ass person that's true
makes you strong a man I also be sure to
subscribe know all of that stuff and
sponsors yes and we want to give a final
shout out to our sponsors for 20% off
your first purchase visit native
deodorant calm and use promo code b-tch
20 during checkout and also visit Noom
calm b tch to start your trial today as
well as thank you to ShoeDazzle go to
ShoeDazzle comm slash b tch to get your
first style for as low as 10 dollars
thank you guys
oh and by the way just really quickly I
really like when it's a conversation in
the comments it really makes me feel
less alone when I share a story and then
people like all I relate to that so if
you have a story or a similar story or
something that we didn't even mention
that you're like did anyone else go
through this leave it in the comments
cuz I want to read it I usually read it
of course yeah and we'll see you next
time
[Music]